little fill-in-the-blank time Chris
pivoting off of what DeSean Jackson said
having every player on the field miked
up would be blank what I mean blank is
the keyword I mean having every player
on the field Mike dump would be a lot of
work for that person that's got to bleep
out cuss words for TV channels or
certain stations because that's exactly
it now it would be awesome it really
would be it would great to be great to
see the behind the scenes look as far as
some of the communications getting to
hear some of the things at the line of
scrimmage but especially the trash talk
the trash talk is awesome in the NFL
there is no doubt about that it gets
personal you know it really does you
know it never goes to crazy but of
course you're going to hear some
four-letter words a lot of four-letter
words there's a lot of cussing that goes
on in that FL field so that's where it
would be dangerous just to have an open
mic of players the NFL is gonna have to
have a whole new person with a with a
separate job just making sure that you
know some of those sound bites don't
have too many swear words I have a
candidate for that job is me
whoever bleeps the profanity out of your
podcast that's probably the same well
train the the here's the thing though
the NFL and its teams will will need I
think a lot of coaxing to go along with
this
look at how bent out of shape the Jets
got over the Sam darn old seeing ghosts
line that made its way through the miked
up segment on Monday Night Football and
how many of those miked up segments were
nothing more than let's go good job all
right
like who cares yeah you're gonna put a
microphone on these guys let's hear
something raw let's hear something real
I'll give you an example from a
different sport go to youtube there are
plenty of videos not now watch the show
there are plenty of videos of hockey
players who are miked up and the things
they say to each other it is fascinating
to hear them interact on the ice and you
want to enhance the broadcast
gonna have no background noise to keep
us from hearing it let's let's hear what
these guys are saying and yes get
Kristin in there with an active use of
the dump button it'll be very painting
even if every other word is bleeped well
that's right I mean you're gonna have to
put like a big red explicit sign you
know before the game comes on to let
people know but the other thing bike I
think you bring up a little bit that's
gonna be very real the way I don't know
if teams are gonna want it you know the
the I don't think any team or head coach
is gonna feel comfortable about you know
their quarterback and everybody being
miked up all the time they're gonna want
to know where those recordings are going
because they're gonna worry about man
people are hearing our plays our signals
and then that's the other thing too I
think coaches and quarterbacks are gonna
be annoyed because they're gonna go well
our code words you can hear them clear
as day on the broadcast and that's gonna
be a lot of changing of signals and
words on a weekly basis to where I think
that would be a little bit of a pushback
point from coaches and quarterbacks if
this does happen and and that's one of
Bill Belichick's fears while he will
never do hard knocks he's afraid of what
ends up on the cutting room floor and
where it goes everybody there was a time
when Nick Saban beat the Patriots by
supposedly picking up stuff from the TV
broadcast definitely the the cadence the
the the calls that were coming through
so yeah there's gonna be a concern about
that although and I had an idea last
week and I can't remember where I said
this but I had an idea about the the
last dance
how ESPN had the one version for
grown-ups
and the other version with the bleeping
now you can't get away with that on an
FCC regulated broadcast but for the
cable broadcast you do two feeds and
yeah yeah they already have a full
embrace of profanity and hard knocks and
in the Amazon program all or nothing why
not go ahead and embrace it if there are
gonna be fans try to find a way to make
chicken salad alright Deion Sanders is
working with Antonio Brown he posted on
social media over the weekend that Deion
Sanders wants to be part of this effort
to get a Antonio Brown back in the
league as I said Deion Sanders need to
take it up with the guy who signs his
NFL Network paychecks because Roger
Goodell is people are
was dragging their feet on multiple
Antonio Brown investigations that have
kept him out of the league while these
investigations have been pending but if
he gets back in well let's just leave it
wide open we don't know what's gonna
happen this season Antonio Brown will be
what Chris what's your prediction making
lots of Instagram stories I mean that's
what I think he's going to be doing I
mean I don't expect to see him on the
field there's there's too many hurdles
that have to be overcome here to think
that he's gonna be playing you know on a
football team in 2020 you know with some
of the legal issues he's got to deal
with off the field then getting cleared
by the commissioner and then you know
again fair or not fair it's gonna be the
same conversation we had earlier in the
show a little bit with Colin Kaepernick
the team's really want to deal with
Antonio Brown okay that's it really
played in two seasons do we want to
bring a guy in here that you know is
gonna cause a stir in our locker room or
have to answer questions about him every
time and if he makes one little false
move or says one bad thing or has bad
bot the bad body language you know
everyone's gonna read into it so you
know I don't expect to see him at a
football field this year I don't to tie
it back to what we were talking about
earlier in the show about distraction
sometimes you're good enough to overcome
distraction last year Antonio Brown was
regarded as good enough to overcome
distraction this year I don't know or
distraction is so big it doesn't matter
one or the other either it's hey this
guy's getting deeper into his 30s we're
not gonna look at all look at all the
great receivers that were drafted this
year right you can find a receiver who
isn't gonna cause you the kind of
trouble the Antonio Brown may and given
what we've seen from the last 15 16
months you're on notice that you're
rolling the dice here on a potential
problem is it worth it and I think most
teams are gonna say it's not one more
very very quickly deshaun Watson says
he's excited about his new weapons he
should be what Chris I want to say he
should be exclamation point exclamation
point exclamation point he should be
excited you know yeah okay you lost the
Andre Hopkins all right they still they
get on a really good wide receiving
court down there in Houston you know
get four guys that are legit like okay
you can go to them in any situation you
know Brandon cooks fuller what's his
name from Randall Cobb and I'm missing
one other that I'm sure Kenny sills
excuse me
but you know they can do it all it's
gonna be hard to figure out who - Shaun
Watson wants to go through this year so
he should be excited all right I he
don't have done what and so I don't know
how excited you don't have DeAndre
Hopkins he should be what he should be
past all right you made me say it hit
the big red button Kristen
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports